HAYES RAFFLE: Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
HAYES RAFFLE: Hi,
I'm Hayes Raffle.
I'm here today with
three colleagues
I've been working with a
long time, Bob Ryskamp, Emmet
Connolly, and Alex Faaborg.
Actually, the four of us go back
a long time in different ways.
Alex and I were at
the MIT Media Lab
together about 10 years ago.
And Bob and Emmet were
on the watch design team,
I think, about three years ago,
doing the very early design
iterations of Android Wear.
And now Alex and Emmet work
together on the Wear team,
and Bob I have been working on
Glass for about three years.
And you guys are sort of getting
four for the price of one
today.
We're here to share with
you some of the things
that we've learned along the
way because over the last three
or four years,
we've been finding
our way through this
new space of wearables
and trying to understand
what it means, what works,
and what direction it makes
sense to go in this new space.
And so I wanted to start with a
little bit of philosophy, some
of the things that
we've found useful
as we've worked
through this space.
And a couple of things that
have been most helpful for me
are some of the things
that Sergey and Larry have
talked about over the years.
Larry talks about how technology
should do the hard work,
and you should have a chance
to live, have a good life,
and get on with it.
And that's great.
And you see that in
products like Google Search
that try and get you what you
need and get out of the way
as fast as possible.
And Sergey talks
about how computing
needs to be more comfortable.
And on their surface,
these might actually
seem like different statements.
One is about form.
The other one's about function.
But they're really
the same idea.
And the idea is that computing
should start to disappear.
It should fade into the
background of our lives.
It should be ephemeral,
not the foreground
of our attention all the time
because life is beautiful.
It's full of beautiful
people and puppies
and sunsets and things that
are just really lovely.
And computing shouldn't be
taking us away from that.
It should be helping to bring
us closer to it, if anything.
And so one of the
phrases that we
use a lot when we're
doing design is we
talk about the world
being the experience.
The user experience, the
experience with the product,
could never possibly compete
with the beautiful things
around you.
At best, it can provide timely
information and help and things
that can help you be
connected to others
and be connected to the
moment that you're in.
And you see that
in lots of aspects
of the design of the
products that we're building.
You see it in the placement
of the Glass display.
It's not in front of you.
It's off on the periphery.
You see that even
in the font weights,
very thin, light strokes
with a black background
which shows up as transparent
on the Glass display.
You see that in some of the use
cases, some of my favorites,
this one of Sebastian Thrun
swinging his son around
in a circle right
after we got the camera
working on Glass
a couple years ago
and showing how technology
could really help transport us
into that moment
of joy that he was
having with his three-year-old.
This is what it
means when we say,
"The world is the experience."
And now my background
actually is in fine art.
And the thing that I
care most about when
I do my work is creating a
sense of empathy between people,
getting people closer
together, because while we talk
so much at Google about
the user experience
and designing for the user,
none of us live in isolation.
We live in a world surrounded
by people that we care about.
And how can technology help
to bring us closer to others?
And I want to show
you a couple examples
that I think are starting
to get in that direction.
This is a picture of a
journalist named Tim Pool.
Tim works for "Vice Magazine."
And about a year ago, he was
in the streets of Istanbul
documenting the riots
that were happening there
and broadcasting live from
Glass to a huge viewer base
that he has.
And Tim's been doing
this for a long time
with cameras on his shoulder,
with his cell phone,
now with Glass.
And I think for me the
transformative thing that's
happening is that
Glass is allowing him
to interview people in
a more intimate way.
When he talks to people
in the street with Glass,
they're not talking
to his camera.
They're talking to him.
And what that means
is that when you're
watching that
broadcast from far away
and trying to understand
what's happening in Istanbul,
you're that much
closer to the action.
You're that much
closer to the way
that people are feeling
in the streets there.
There's another thing
that we think a lot
about with wearables and
this idea of being connected.
Wearables themselves
are very, very intimate.
You're wearing
them on your body.
In fact, these glasses are
so specially designed for me,
if you put them on, you
probably can't see then
because I have my
prescription on them.
They're very hard to share.
And in the same token, the way
that we design the experience
for wearables needs
to be very personal.
It needs to reflect the
things about me as the wearer
that I find important.
It needs to be about the
closest people, the people
that I care about who are close
both in time and in space,
whether it's my family or you
who are in this room with me
right now.
It's about surfacing the
information from the people
you care about in a way
that feels personal to you.
It's about being able to bring
your niece to her grandmother's
birthday party to see 100
candles get blown out,
even if she couldn't
be there in person.
Again, this is what we mean by,
"The world is the experience."
Now one of the tactics that we
talk about, how do you do this?
And we're going to talk about
some different ways today.
But the first one that
I want to talk about
is called micro interactions.
And the idea with
micro interactions
is that wearables
are on the periphery.
You're not designing
the windshield.
You're designing what goes
in the rear view mirror
because whatever is happening in
front of the user in their life
is going to be demanding.
It's going to be happening fast.
And it's going to need
most of their attention.
And whatever you're giving them
needs to be very glanceable.
And this idea of
glanceability is really
about getting to the
essence of the information
that that person needs
in the time and the place
that they are.
And so what does that mean
in how you design software?
Well, if you look at driving
directions on Glass, when
you ask for directions,
for the most part,
the screen is turned off.
But before you
have to turn, it'll
turn on and tell you, turn
right on Greenwich Avenue
in 100 feet, show you a map
of where you need to go,
and then after you've completed
the turn, disappear again.
This is glanceable.
This is what it means to be
the rear view mirror, not
the windshield.
It means when you're designing
a messaging app for the watch,
how minimal can you make it?
What is the simplest
amount of information
that the user needs to
get the task completed?
Here's two designs.
And the big difference between
them is that one of them
has twice as much
information as the other one.
On the left, six pieces
of information for a user
to look at, on the
right only three.
That difference is
about 900 milliseconds
of attention for
someone who's focused.
Now 900 milliseconds, why
would you care about that?
Well, you have to remember
this person's wearing it
on their wrist.
They might be running
to the next meeting.
Which one of these
would you rather
have if you're running to the
next session in room seven?
We've even played
around with, could we
put an emulator like this
into the developer tools
that you could play with this?
But I think the real idea,
and Timothy mentioned earlier,
is that none of this stuff
is particularly intuitive.
It's taken us a long time to
get to where we're at today.
And there's certainly
a long way to go still.
And the way that
we make progress
is by continually testing
on the device in the context
where we mean to
use these things.
This is sort of a
paradigm shift, I think,
because if you look at the way
that people use their phones
today, people get
out their phone,
and then they do their task.
And then they get distracted
by a lot of other things
that are there.
They got lost in
their phone, and they
are taken out of the world.
And what we're trying to do
with wearables is actually
get to a place where people
have the same utility
and benefit from computing,
but there's actually
less computing in their
life because we've
designed experiences
for them that
are much more compact so
they can get in and out,
get their goal completed.
Put another way, I
think our job now
as designers and developers
is to create experiences that
are as short as possible,
as fast as possible,
to complete the task that
the user needs to do.
So we're going to talk more
about different strategies
that we've developed and
ideas we have to do that.
And I want to turn
over the stage now
to Bob, who's going to talk
about some of the things
he's learned about voice.
Bob's been wearing computers
since they weren't quite so
wearable, and so he has a
lot of perspective on it.
BOB RYSKAMP: Thanks, Hayes.
So ever since the
bike helmet days,
we've been designing
our wearable products
to help you be more engaged
with the real world.
And one way that we've done
that is through creating
natural language voice
interfaces for our products.
We've tried a lot of different
interaction techniques
for Wear and for Glass.
And one thing we found is that
when you can speak naturally
to a device, just like
you and I could talk,
it makes your
interactions much faster.
It makes it much easier
to stay connected
to the people you're with
and the places you're in.
And for wearables, this
is even more important
than for some other devices.
For instance, Hayes and I
both love to go cycling.
And this is a fantastic place
in the world to go cycling.
It's a sport that's
all about the outdoors,
but it's also got a bunch
of just amazing technology
that you can really get into.
And it's an example
of an activity where,
like Hayes said, the
world is the experience.
And it's very, very important
to pay attention to it.
And I also love my phone.
But that same gorgeous
phone interface
that works so well when
I'm sitting and standing
doesn't work as well
when I'm active.
Maybe my hands are sweaty.
I'm trying to ride
at the same time,
trying to hit those
small icons on a screen.
Maybe the sun is
causing some glare.
So we felt that
Glass and wearables
could be great to
use while cycling.
You can keep your hands
on the handlebars.
You can keep your
eyes on the road.
It works with your voice.
But when we first started
designing the interfaces
for Glass, we tried to use a
lot of the same interaction
and visual design
patterns that we
knew from designing for
phones and desktops.
We had a screen.
We put it roughly in the
middle of your perspective.
You'd first try to
choose an app to run,
and then you'd select
a few features.
You'd choose an option.
Then maybe finally you
could view individual items.
You could input
some information.
And with all of
those steps, we found
that we weren't really
getting a different experience
from the phone.
You still have to
think about, what's
the structure of my
operating system?
And what features
does each app have?
And where do I input those
information into those fields?
Now this is a very
powerful system,
which is why we use it
on desktops and phones.
But it didn't feel appropriate
for a wearable device.
And when you step back
and think about it,
when you're engaged
with the real world,
your interactions
aren't like that.
If you're cycling with
a group of friends,
you're not opening menu
options and clicking buttons.
You're looking at people,
and you're talking to them.
You're seeing things,
you point at them.
You reach for things
and hold them.
These are all very
natural interactions.
You don't need a manual to
tell you how to do them.
And so we wanted as
much as possible to make
our experiences on
wearables more like that.
For instance, we designed the
messaging experience on Glass
to be as close as
possible to the way you'd
talk to a close friend.
OK, Glass, send a
message to Jane Williams.
Hey, Jane.
It was great to see you today.
We even show a photo of the
person in the background
while you're talking.
Overall, we wanted
to make it feel
like that face to
face conversation,
except now you could do
it across time and space.
Now this cuts out a whole bunch
of the decisions and steps
required to do that same
action on a phone or a desktop.
And it turns out to
be tremendously faster
than pulling your phone out and
manipulating all those options.
That's because when we designed
the messaging Glassware,
we chose just a
single experience,
sending one message
to a single contact.
And we designed a unique voice
command and a unique flow
for just that experience.
Now if you want to look
at an older message
or you want to
edit your contacts,
you want to do any of the
other things you think
of belong a messaging
application,
you can do those in other
ways in other places.
But this experience is very
singular and very focused.
You do just one thing at a
time, and you see just one thing
at a time.
And with Android Wear, we
wanted to bring that same kind
of experience to a
lot more devices.
As you saw in today's
keynote, if you
have a car service or a ride
sharing application installed,
you can simply speak a command.
OK, Google, call me a car.
It's a simple natural
language command.
It instantly gets a
car headed your way.
Again, it's almost like
you're able to talk across
the city directly to the driver.
So one thing you can do to make
your wearable interface more
natural is to carefully
design that voice experience.
Don't just pour it over
the structure of your app
from your mobile
device or your desktop.
Think very carefully
about, what's
that individual short experience
that people want to have?
And break up that bit app
into individual flows.
And then you can design and
craft one single voice action
just for that flow and
just get that person
that perfect experience and
make that as much like normal
speech as possible.
We believe that natural
language speech, when
it's connected to all
the amazing services
that all of you are
building, is going
to make interacting with
wearables even easier
and faster than using
phones and desktops.
But this example of
calling for a car
also does something else
to improve the experience.
And that's use knowledge about
your context and where you are.
So I'll next hand
over to Emmet, who
is one of the founding
designers of the Wear project.
And he'll walk you
through how we've
been designing using context.
Emmet and I worked
in Zurich together
while he was working on
some of these early ideas,
so I got to see all of his crazy
embarrassing early prototypes
as well.
EMMET CONNOLLY: Hi, everyone.
So Bob talked about
how speaking a command
can be one of the fastest
and easiest ways of actually
performing an action.
And I'm going to talk
about one way that's
potentially even
faster than that.
And that's to not even
speak a command at all,
to just have the right
information appear
automatically based
solely on the context
that the user is in.
So let's rewind for a minute.
This is a wooden prototype
of the Palm Pilot
that Jeff Hawkins made when
they were first designing
and developing it, one of
the first portable computers.
It's a little stylus, a
chopstick stylus, there.
I love that.
So before they ever
started building anything,
Jeff used to carry this
around with him every day.
And if someone said
to him, hey, are
you free at 3 o'clock
today, or whatever,
he would pull out his
little wooden computer
and tap away on it
with his chopstick
and pretend to actually
check if he was free.
He would do this
every day for months.
And what he was
actually doing was
trying to figure out what it was
like to use a device like this,
a new type of device at the
time, on a day to day basis
and in a regular
day to day context.
He was trying to figure
out what kind of UI
might feel right for
this new form factor.
And in retrospect, he was trying
to avoid a common mistake.
It seems like that very often
when these new devices come
along, the general
reaction seems
to be to take the dominant
paradigm, UI paradigm,
of the day and just slap
it on these new devices.
And the truth is, that never
really works out all that well.
You have these new
types of devices,
and they're often really begging
for some new interface ideas.
And to a certain extent,
we've seen this play out
with the early wearables
market as well.
A lot of these
devices are really
just taking the grid of apps and
putting it on this tiny screen.
And again, we see that this
doesn't often really work out
so well.
To start with, these are
really tiny tap targets.
And so especially on a moving
target, it's hard to hit.
You can't see very many
of these icons at once,
so it's hard to build up
a spatial memory of even
where everything is located.
And it can just take
a lot of swiping
to go through all these
screens and actually access
what it is that you're
trying to access
to even start with your action.
So we took a step
back from this.
And we tried to
think about, what
if we didn't require any
input at all, that we just
had the right information
show up at the right time.
And this is what
we came up with.
So some of you notice the subtle
detail in this photograph.
Yes, it's just a phone
strapped to a wrist.
Well done.
But there is something
interesting happening here.
This is an actual
prototype that we built.
And there's no
grid of apps here.
There is just one
simple clear piece
of information
showing up at a time.
And if another piece of
information comes along,
and that's more important
for the user to know about,
then we'll show that instead.
So we kept thinking about this.
We thought, what if there's more
than one piece of information
that's useful to know about?
Maybe we could arrange these
simple screens as a row
or as a group of cards,
and you could just
rank them and have the
most important stuff
appear at the top.
And you see this
thinking today reflected
in the philosophy of
the Android Wear UI
and also of the Glass UI.
In both devices, there's just
this targeted relevant piece
of information.
And in both devices, the way
that you interact with them
is the same.
You're just swiping through this
really clear stream of cards.
And it feels like
roughly the right level
of interaction for these devices
in terms of the ergonomics,
visually how they appear, and
just the overall interaction.
So it's kind of a nice
UI model for wearables.
But we still have
this problem of,
how do we know when to show
the right piece of information?
When do we put this
information in front of users?
Well, there's something
special about these devices.
They're packed
with these sensors.
They're aware of their
situation and state.
They're aware of the context
that they're being used in.
For example, your
application can
know where the user
is, potentially
where they're headed.
And then you can ask
yourself, what's nearby?
What might be useful for
the user to know about?
Your app obviously knows
what time of day it is
and what date it is.
And the user may have
granted permission
to access their
events and what's
important to them coming up.
There is of course the identity
of the user, their patterns,
their preferences, their habits.
And then these devices
also have motion sensors.
And because they're
worn on the body,
we can transfer this raw motion
information into activities.
And we actually have APIs
that are available to you
as developers that can sense
these simple activities
that you can pattern match
against, things like walking,
cycling, driving, and so on.
These devices are connected,
of course, and often
to other nearby devices.
So you can start
to ask questions
like, what is the
phone doing right now?
Is the TV being used?
Maybe there's music
streaming to the speaker.
Maybe the thermostat
knows something.
And these are all signals
that add into this context.
And finally there are
additional sensors,
some of them built
into the Wear.
I could get a
spare-- no, I'm back.
OK.
Is it me?
I'll try and keep going.
Thanks.
Yeah, so there
are nearby devices
that can provide the
other information, perhaps
like a precise location
from Bluetooth beacons.
So the real interesting
thing happens
when we take the combined total
of all of this sensor data
and put it together into
one single rich picture
of the user's situation,
the scenario that they're
in right now.
So as developers, we can
look at this situation
and we can ask
ourselves the question,
how can we present the user
with useful information
that will help them?
And for you guys as
developers, what you can do
is define detailed
contextual trigger conditions
and have your app show up
at precisely the right time
based on those
trigger conditions.
So let's look at a
practical example now.
So first we'll look at a typical
interaction as it exists today.
Let's say you're
going for a run.
You probably pull
out your phone,
then you launch a running
app, maybe tap in some goals.
You might decide to switch
over to a music app,
queue up that album that you
had been listening to earlier,
switch back to the
running app, tap Start
so that you can get going,
strap the phone onto your arm.
And off you go.
Fairly typical interaction
that we're probably used to.
Now we'll try and redesign
this experience for wearables
using context to
drive the interaction.
So in this case, assume you're
using an Android Wear device.
It's a pleasant
Sunday afternoon.
You're at the head
of your running trail
that maybe you run
at most Sundays.
You probably just stretch
out, plug in your headphones,
and start running.
So based just on the simple
inputs from our sensors,
the things that we
can detect, things
like the time, the location,
your habits, physical movement,
even what the headphone
jack is doing,
it really looks like this person
is going for a run right now.
So why shouldn't we
do the obvious thing
and present them with
helpful information?
In this case, it would be
something like start tracking
their run and perhaps also offer
to pick up playing that album.
So the user didn't have to
do very much at all here.
They just acted as
they normally would.
And the technology does the
right thing automatically.
It was like Hayes said.
The world is the experience,
and the technology just
adapts to what
the user is doing.
So again, rather
than asking the user
to manually tell the device
what they want to do and then
have to manage state
on an ongoing basis,
on wearables we're going to
do something much simpler
than that.
We're going to do all the
heavy lifting for them based
on context and present them
with just the right information
at the right time.
So that was a simple example.
Next up, Alex is going to talk
you through some more examples
and also introduce you
to some design tools that
will help you
apply this thinking
to your own applications.
ALEX FAABORG: All right.
So that was a lot
of information.
And this is a new
form factor, so that
means thinking about building
entirely new types of software.
But it also means a
lot of opportunities
to build breakthrough
applications
because this is
a new form factor
and we're just getting started.
So first let's summarize.
Hayes talked about how the
world is the experience, sunsets
and puppies and
these things that we
care about more than having
to interact with devices.
And how do we achieve the
world being the experience?
Well, we achieve it by having
the user be in the world more.
And we can do that
through micro interactions
so that you're more present
ad engaged in the real world.
But you're also more
connected virtually
because you have more check-ins.
It's just your engagement with
the technology is shorter.
How do we make those
engagements shorter?
How do we achieve
micro interactions?
Well, the two core components,
voice, as Bob talked about,
and context, as
Emmet talked about.
So now you're thinking, OK.
That sounds cool, but
where do I actually start?
I want to build an application.
We've got this OS that's built
around voice and context,
but how do I translate my app?
How do I build an entirely
new app for this platform?
And of course it's good to start
sketching, but at this stage,
you're just looking at
a blank piece of paper,
and you're kind of lost.
So I want you to consider
two thought experiments
to kind of ground
your thinking in how
to approach wearable
applications.
So the first one's about voice.
Now imagine that
you are your app.
And the only way that the
user can communicate with you
is through voice.
So as the app, you're
sitting in a room.
It's a very nice white room.
And the only thing in
the room is a pedestal,
and there's this
red telephone on it.
And when the user
needs something,
that telephone's going to ring.
Then you're going to answer
it, and it's the user.
And they're going to say exactly
what they need from the app.
So what's the first
thing that the user
says when you pick
up that phone?
What's the range of
calls that you're
expecting to get
throughout the day?
How does the user
phrase the request?
And the great thing
about building
on top of Google's
voice recognition system
is that we're building out
all of the capabilities.
We're actually handling
all of the transcription
and natural language
processing and grammars.
And all you have to
do is just subscribe
to a particular intent.
But then the question is,
which intents do you want?
So as we're building
up the system,
we really definitely
want to hear from you
about the applications
you're trying to build
and which voice intents you're
interested in so we can start
working on those and getting
those into the system
so that your apps can
subscribe to them.
So you can go to this form,
just fill it out and tell us
what you're interested
in the voice recognition
system being capable of.
And we'll show some examples
of what it can currently do.
So the second thought
experiment is about context.
And as Emmet said,
even faster than voice
is the application
being able to anticipate
the information that you need.
So for here, I want you
to think about this moment
where a surgeon
reaches out their hand
and immediately, without
ever having to look away,
the tool that they need
is placed in that hand.
And what's interesting
about context
is contextual currents
aren't meant to be surprises.
Users are going to reach
out their hand for your app
at various times.
They're going to
adapt to the system
as much as the system's
adapting to them.
And they're expecting
the app to be there.
So imagine that
you're with the user
and you have the app ready.
And you're ready to give the
user the app at any moment.
When do you expect the user
to reach their hand out?
What's going on
in that situation?
What's the environment?
And then as you
think about that,
you can think about how you can
build the contextual trigger
conditions so that
the card is there
on their device at
just the right moment.
So we're almost ready to
start sketching our app,
but we still have this
blank piece of paper.
And one thing that's
really useful for sketching
applications is, of
course, stencils.
This is a stencil that was made
for Android phone applications.
And it's really great.
You have all the patterns,
and you can quickly
sketch out all of your screens.
So then the question
is, well, what
does a stencil look like
for wearable applications?
So we started playing
around with that.
And we haven't
actually built it,
but here's a picture of what
we think it would look like.
So what's sort of interesting
is of course voice, right?
We're just hoping to have
something with speech bubbles,
where you can draw speech
bubbles, sort of sketch what
you expect the user to say.
And then next we have context,
all the contextual trigger
conditions that Emmet
was talking about.
And only then do we move
on to then sketching
the actual UI on the watch,
the card that appears
or the screen that's a
result of the voice action.
So let's look at some
examples of voice.
The talk's been
pretty high level,
but I want to run through
some very specific examples,
a few apps that are
actually already available.
So imagine you're going
furniture shopping,
and you see a new
couch that you're
interested in that
you want to remember.
You can just say, OK,
Google, take a note.
And apps can subscribe to
the take a note intent.
So in this case, Evernote
is the user's favorite note
application, but it could be
any number of note applications
that the user likes to use.
Say you're going for the
run, back to Emmet's example.
And as you're running,
you're curious
what your heart rate is.
So you can just say, OK,
Google, what's my heart rate?
And if the device
has the sensor,
that'll be available just
with a quick voice command.
And this is another intent
that we currently support.
Then at the end of the run,
if you want to stop recording,
you can just say, OK,
Google, stop running.
And apps can subscribe
to that intent.
So we have all of these various
natural language processing
grammars built up for
all the different ways
that users can say these things.
But from the app side, all
they have to think about
is they're subscribing to
stop a run or take a note
or what the basic intents are.
Let's look at some
examples for context.
There's a few really
good ones on Glass
that are already shipping.
This is LynxFit.
Developers are
actually in the room.
They did an awesome job.
[? Huzzah, Bob ?] might say.
It's so good.
So how this works is it's
going to use motion sensors
to actually watch
you do the workout.
And it guides you
by speaking to you
and showing you quick
little video clips.
And it really works like
a personal trainer would
in real life, in that it's
giving you instructions
and it's actually
observing your motion.
And this is great.
I mean, it doesn't get
more contextual than this.
It's like actually
recording each motion.
Another example of
context is Field Trip,
where this shows you information
about your surroundings.
In this case, the user's
interested in history,
so they're seeing some
historical information.
This one's pretty crazy.
It's 94Fifty.
It uses a special
basketball that
has sensors that can
sense your shot style.
And it gives you feedback
on the shot on Glass.
This is also kind of a good
example of the world being
the experience because,
really, the experience
here is you're
shooting a basketball.
But this is just giving
you some additional data
to help you have a better shot.
Similar example with golf.
This is Swingbyte,
which connects
to a sensor on your club.
And this logs all sorts
of really useful data
as you're playing.
In some ways, it's
kind of like a caddy,
but it's even more
accurate than a caddy
because it has really
detailed information.
So let's look at some
examples on Wear.
So imagine your friend has an
Pinterest board of the best
gummy candy in North America.
And of course, you're
going to subscribe to that.
So you subscribed to
it a long time ago.
You've since forgotten.
But as you're traveling
and you're walking around,
Pinterest fires,
and it says, hey,
one of the pins that
you're interested in
is actually walking distance.
You can go check it out because
it knew that that was something
that you were interested in.
And this is currently available.
Another great application from
Trulia, this one's really cool.
So as you're going to
open houses, when you're
near the property it's
going to show information
about the property.
It gives you actions like
you can call the agent.
You can quickly
favorite the property.
And again, this is very much
the world is the experience.
It's kind of like you're
right clicking on the world.
It's like the world has
a contextual menu where
you can just say, like,
favorite this property, which
I think this one's really cool.
All right.
So let's look at a few more
were hypothetical examples.
So imagine you're at home.
Your device detects that
you're at home, gives you
controls for your thermostat.
Imagine you're going skiing and
the conditions are pretty icy.
But since you're inside the
grounds of the ski resort,
your device could
just tell you which
lifts are running, which
trails have been groomed,
all the contextual information
that you want right then.
Imagine you're at the airport.
And as you're scrolling
through your cards,
you see that the
airline that you're on
is providing information on
how many miles you've acquired
and how you're doing.
You're staying at a
hotel, and the hotel chain
recognizes that you're on
one of their properties.
They can give you
quick access to actions
like requesting
a late check-out.
Imagine you're at a conference.
Social network could
tell you, hey, here's
some friends that you have
that you haven't actually
seen in a long time.
But they're also
at the conference,
if you guys want to meet up.
If you're at a restaurant,
a nutritional application
could detect which
restaurant chain you're in,
quickly look up nutritional
information for that chain
and provide suggestions of the
healthiest items on the menu.
Say you're getting the
oil changed in your car.
You could have an
assistant application
that recognizes
that and just offers
to set a reminder for
another six months.
You're at the zoo, and you
have a watch that automatically
knows when the penguins
are going to be fed.
Imagine if you're
able to ask real time
location-based questions.
And people using
the service could
choose if they
wanted to respond.
And these wouldn't
be interruptive.
But if you saw one come by
as you were using the device
and you felt like responding,
you could help them out.
So questions that you could
otherwise never search
for, you could use,
like saying, are there
any picnic tables free, and
getting an answer to that.
Imagine you're using
a car sharing service.
And as you approach
the vehicle, you
get a quick action
to unlock the car.
So what's sort of interesting
about all those examples
is that the UI wasn't
actually that complicated.
The UI's usually just
a card or a button.
And when you look
at the stencil,
there's not much of the
stencil devoted to the UI.
This isn't about sketching
a variety of different UI
widgets.
What the stencil is about
is the user and their world.
It's about what the
user's going to say.
It's about what the contextual
trigger conditions are.
Even with our mock-ups,
we focused more
on sort of the
background of the scene
than when the device came up.
So what's really
important when thinking
about these wearable
applications
is thinking about the world
and what the user needs.
And we ran through
a bunch of them,
but this brings us back to our
overall notion of the world
being the experience.
It's really being the
thing that drives the use
cases for these
wearable applications.
And the world's a big place.
So there's really
a tremendous amount
of opportunity for really
interesting applications built
in this space by
designers and developers.
Google's crafting the
infrastructure with APIs
for voice and context that
you guys can build on.
And this is in the same spirit
as our initial work on Google
Now, but we're opening
up the platform
to the entire ecosystem for
contextual cards and voice
actions.
And really, together we'll
be able to build things
that are really
far beyond anything
that we could build on our own.
So a quick
announcement, which you
may have heard in
the last session.
If you're watching
this on video,
check out Timothy's session,
Wearable Computing at Google.
Wear notifications
are going to start
appearing on Glass in the
next few months, which
will make life much easier for
developers because they can
develop for both
devices simultaneously.
And this will get you
access to pages, stacks,
voice replies, and actions.
And with that, we'd love
to take your questions.
Thank you.
Any questions?
BOB RYSKAMP: We've got
microphones in the center
if you want to step up to those.
Give people a second.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question
about the Wear.
And [? blocking ?]
out the SDK doesn't
allow you to modify
the notifications
that it can post
from your phone APK.
Is there a reason why the
design has been in such a way
that the developer
doesn't fully control
the layout of the notification?
You have to actually
build an APK for the Wear
in order to do design a layout
that uses the full screen.
You're sort of bound
in that tiny square
of the notification.
What was the reasoning behind?
ALEX FAABORG: So the nice
thing about developers
using templates is then as
new form factors come out,
those notifications can
be automatically adapted
to the new form factor.
Even for Wear, we have square
and circular devices, right?
So that's pretty useful.
So it provides less
work for the developer
when you're using one
of those templates
because you just know
you're sort of guaranteed
for all future form factors.
But you can of course
create an activity view
and control every
pixel if you want.
Then it's more overhead for
testing on the new devices
and making sure everything's
working correctly.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Is there a plan in
the future where
you would allow developers
to completely custom design
the layout of the notifications?
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah, that
actually launched today.
The Wear SDK lets
you do activity views
inside cards, where
you can do the full UI.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
ALEX FAABORG: No problem.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Jonathan.
I want to ask when
will we see some more
sensors on the
Android Wear devices?
I mean, temperature,
moisture, some more.
I mean, the LG doesn't
have a heart rate.
And most of the really
interesting applications
would be around more sensors.
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah.
Well, I think as people are
seeing the types of apps
that developers want to build
and the ecosystem's growing,
we're going to see a lot of
innovation in this space.
And one of the great
things about Wear
is we're going to
have lots of devices.
So that will enable competition
in the marketplace for people
to add sensors and have
really cool use cases.
AUDIENCE: Any known
watches coming out
with multiple sensors?
ALEX FAABORG: I can't-- I'm
not going to preannounce other
watches.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ALEX FAABORG: Theoretically.
AUDIENCE: Thank you all
for the presentation.
So you've been mentioning
all these things
where smartwatches and
smartglasses are similar
and how Android Wear is going to
work with both Glass and Wear.
So my question is
exactly the opposite.
Where do you see Glass and
smartwatches being totally very
different?
And this is for any of you.
What's the feature where
a smartwatch makes sense
but Glass doesn't,
and vice versa?
ALEX FAABORG: You want
to take that, Bob?
BOB RYSKAMP: Sure.
I think as Timothy Jordan
said in the last session,
a lot of it does come down
to the individual user,
what people's preferences are.
I think one thing I've
found while working
on wearable devices is they're
much more like other things you
wear like shoes and socks and
shirts and jackets and hats
and actually less like phones
and tablets in a lot of ways,
in that you might
one day wear one,
another day wear
another, depending
on what you plan to do that day.
For example, myself, I love to
wear the watch around my house.
It frees me from my phone,
which can be downstairs
and I can still get
my notifications.
But I love to wear Glass when
I'm cycling or when I'm playing
with my one-and-a-half-year-old.
It's the world's
best baby camera.
So I'll take one off,
put one on depending
on what I want to do that day.
I think that's probably the
future of wearable technology,
is that sort of use
case, very flexible.
And people get to choose and
customize for themselves.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
ALEX FAABORG: Another thing to
consider as an app developer is
if the user has to maintain
eye contact with something,
then Glass is definitely better.
So, like, the basketball example
works really long on Glass,
but I don't think
you'd necessarily
want to be looking down at your
watch while playing basketball.
So there's some significant
sort of form factor differences
to consider for
your specific case.
AUDIENCE: My name's
Julie Stanford,
and I run a UX design agency
called Sliced Bread where
we do a lot of
interactive prototyping
like the kind you showed.
And we use a lot of HTML jQuery
to do just quick Wizard of Oz
prototypes.
And I'm wondering
if Android Wear is
going to support doing that
type of quick prototyping
without having to go through
creating a back end and di di
dah, or if there's
just some quick way
to do rapid prototyping
on that platform.
ALEX FAABORG: Well, it should.
It doesn't currently.
AUDIENCE: OK.
But it will?
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah.
Well, I mean it
should in theory.
Yeah.
It's still pretty early.
The team's been really focused
on getting a product out
before we've been able to do
more robust things like helping
prototypers and stuff.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So you can't just, like,
create something HTML
and quickly show it to
see how it might work?
ALEX FAABORG: No, it doesn't
have a rendering engine.
BOB RYSKAMP: But I would say,
don't let that discourage you.
Strap a bicycle helmet to your
head or a phone to your wrist.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I'm
not discouraged.
BOB RYSKAMP: We'll
all designers.
We actually did a bunch in
HTML and JavaScript prototypes.
And the real important
thing is that you can just
wear it and try it
in any way possible.
ALEX FAABORG: You could
also just draw out
a smaller area of a phone screen
and have people read that.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Makes sense.
ALEX FAABORG: I mean,
that stuff works OK.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Just a quick question.
I'm just thinking
about on average
most people have, like, 50 apps.
And there's a lot
of competing apps
and a lot of
competing information.
So let's say, where
should I eat tonight?
Which card comes up?
Something from Foursquare,
something from Yelp?
Or, where should I stay tonight?
Does Airbnb give me a
suggestion or Hotel Tonight?
I'm just wondering how does
wearable kind of tackle that,
or I mean Android Wear?
ALEX FAABORG: So
the first time you
say it, if you have
multiple apps installed
or after you've installed
a new application,
the user has a menu
of choices they
can choose for the
application at that moment.
In the future, it's going
to default to the one
that you previously selected.
But it gives you a moment
to pause and choose
one of the others, which
is kind of nice for voice
because you can say a
command, just drop your arm,
and it's just going to happen.
Or you could say a command and
then quickly pause it and say,
now I want to switch over
to this other service.
Also in the campaign
app, you can
set which defaults are
associated with everything.
AUDIENCE: And in terms
of the passive cards
and the ranking of the
order, is that determined
by Google in terms of what's
most relevant to you as you
kind of scroll through the
different decks of cards?
ALEX FAABORG: At
the moment, it's
determined by a number of
signals that the developers are
providing, priority levels.
In the future we're looking
at ranking based off
of how contextual things are.
So it's kind of working hand
in hand with the developers
to understand what's
important about their card
and how it fits in.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Hi.
My name is Conrad, and I work
at the University of Washington.
I'm a grad student there.
And a number of my colleagues
are working on accessibility,
and they're all really
excited about wearables
because they're adding
more modalities for people
that are blind or
that can't hear.
And it's all really exciting.
And so I'm wondering,
is your team
working on any accessibility
technologies with wearables?
Like for instance,
you have a screen,
and you can put Talkback,
which is on Android phones,
on to watches as well.
Are you working on
anything like that?
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah.
I don't want to talk too much
about what we're working on
in the future, but
I think something
that is really exciting
is, particularly
with Glass, the voice feedback.
And building natural voice
interactions, of course,
are incredibly
accessible, and they also
benefit everyone, just as
the sidewalk ramps benefit
everyone.
So even if it's done
initially for accessibility,
it's super powerful to
give everyone access to it.
HAYES RAFFLE: And I think
on the Glass platform
we've seen most innovation
for accessibility
from third parties, a lot of it
actually from academic sectors,
people doing really
innovative stuff.
I think that from
our point of view,
we're trying to design
more towards what
I'd call universal access, which
is how to make stuff that's
as usable as possible
for everybody.
But a lot of these
ideas transfer over
to the accessibility space.
And of course there's some
that don't and some custom work
that needs to be done.
But the developer community's
been amazing and productive
in that space so far with Glass.
And I expect to see
more about with Wear
as the platform emerges.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you.
I have a question
regarding context.
Is it possible to
provide custom contexts?
So for example,
if I can actually
have an algorithm that
determines whether I'm
in a noisy room or
in a quiet place,
or any other type
of custom context,
is that something
that I can actually
use to trigger certain
mechanisms in wearables?
EMMET CONNOLLY: Yeah.
So from the user's
point of view,
we'd prefer to keep
it really simple,
where they didn't need to do
a lot of setting up of trigger
conditions and so on, just
have things to appear.
But I think you might be
asking from an app developer's
point of view.
And we would
absolutely encourage
you to use every single
signal possible to really
focus and target
content to the users.
So all of those examples
that you specified, I think,
are great signals
and really paint
that picture of what
the user is doing.
AUDIENCE: So I'm asking
if I can actually
do a custom context to create
a trigger, a custom trigger.
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah.
So it somewhat depends on
the hardware being used.
So like for Microphone, there's
permissions surrounding that.
Also there's battery
implications.
And the other aspect
is we're trying
to build systems that are
pretty robust that everyone can
benefit from, like with
activity detection.
It's really hard to do machine
learning on accelerometer data
to figure out the difference
between biking and driving.
So by us providing that to
all the developers, then
they get all of that
learning for free.
But for the things
that you can't access,
yeah, we totally
encourage you guys
to build your own
models of context.
It'll give you a leg up in the
market against your competitors
if you're more contextual.
AUDIENCE: OK.
EMMET CONNOLLY: And raw sensor
data is available to you.
For example, in the
accelerometer case,
like if you don't want to,
you don't have to use those.
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah.
If you have a better
model, then yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could
that be triggered?
I mean, I can't use that
to trigger anything, right,
raw accelerometer data?
Accelerometer data, I can't
use that to trigger something
from the background, right?
BOB RYSKAMP: It seems like maybe
we can follow up afterward?
We can talk in more depth.
ALEX FAABORG: Generally, you
can put a card into the stream
whenever you feel
that it's contextual.
BOB RYSKAMP: We'll take just
one more question, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Well, this is crazy.
You just stole my question.
But I'll add a little bit more.
You guys have been working on
this space for a while now.
Do you have any sort of
conceptual frameworks
for thinking about
multiplexing contextual data?
You can often be overwhelmed
by a particular signal
or have a particular signal
that is not represented as well.
Is there any sort of, more
towards the theoretical side
of, like, where to go to
combine these things together?
ALEX FAABORG: It would
be a really good problem
for us to have because right
now we're figuring out context
and then matching that against
all the available sources
of information that have
cards that can match.
At the moment Android Wear
is just launching now,
so we don't have a tremendous
number of applications.
But it'd be a great
problem for us to have,
that suddenly there's
too many contextual cards
for your environment.
And then we'd have to
think about ranking.
And then that's the sort of
fundamentally a search problem.
So I think we're
hopefully pretty well
equipped to tackle it.
I'm looking forward to that
being something we can work on.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
BOB RYSKAMP: So go forth
and give us that problem.
ALEX FAABORG: Yes, please.
BOB RYSKAMP: Thanks, everyone.
HAYES RAFFLE: Yeah, thanks
very much, everybody.